yo my name is Jason right now I'm living
in San Antonio Texas I was in the
military for 31 years and now I'm
retired
chris hogan here i've spent a lot of
time on the road speaking with people
about their millionaire success stories
whether I'm at an event talking with
someone focused on a plan or talking on
my podcast about self-made millionaires
one thing is very clear most people have
no idea what the average millionaire
looks like you're about to step into the
life of someone who crossed over to
millionaire status on their own terms
it's the result of compound discipline
over time so here we go people it's the
next episode of millionaire Jason is in
San Antonio hey Jason how are you doing
good how are you sir better than I
deserve what is your net worth sir two
million dollars two million dollars very
cool so in the beginning
growing up I guess very early I learned
about hard work and my dad taught me
about harder hard work he also taught me
about how to say that is how to save
money learned a little bit about
compound interest a very young age so
with that I really didn't even start to
save until I was 25 years of age that
was after I I had a college degree but
before that going through college I
never went into any type of debt because
I had a Reserve Officer Training Corps
scholarship ROTC scholarship I had that
and eventually I decided to make my
career in the military initially when I
started I was a field artillery a field
artillery is putting rounds downrange
putting big bombs downrange and started
out making I would say 25,000 30,000
whenever even in my highest years I
never went above about a hundred and
thirty thousand so on average I was
going sixty to eighty thousand a year
yeah I think that anybody can become a
millionaire and doesn't matter if you're
making 30,000 or 50,000 a year and I
think the key was just for me us is just
living below your means just like you
would get on a diet or just like you
would say I want to quit my cokes and I
want to go to water or if whatever you
want to do is a change of behavior and
so I think that's the more difficult
part and you can get there on posts you
have folks in fun you've got you've got
a financial support center on all major
posts where you can go to and talk to
them counselors so if you have questions
about how do I get a drift savings plan
or should I buy this car you're going to
have folks that can counsel you and talk
to you there's other opportunities with
the military community to be deployed to
invest if you're deployed you're going
to make more money and there are
opportunities where you can invest in
the Thrift Savings Plan tax-exempt and
above and beyond what you would normally
be able to participate in if you were
not employed what you do is you just got
to start quickly as you can can only if
you can start now start now because you
don't want to procrastinate it because
the earlier you do it
the more time is on your side to become
a millionaire and though and actually
the earlier you do it the least amount
you have to save to become a beginner if
you can just start now and if it's only
$25 a month that you can afford or $50 a
month go ahead and do that until the
best thing to do is put in just to an
automatic investment plan and don't
worry about the markets because the
markets they go up and down but over
time they always go up and they did for
me as well and you're going to hear
things on the news about this or that
and because you just sort of got stay
with it
[Music]
if I can teach my daughter or other
folks to do it what will happen is by
living the example of being a
millionaire are showing compound
interest or showing that you can save a
little and that you can do this they're
going to do the same thing to lurk you
then you'll just create other folks who
who live the life of millionaires when I
went through high school okay I didn't
graduate in the top ten I can tell you
exactly what I graduated I was in a 37%
tile and this was when schools from
South Carolina I didn't really learn how
to write and read too well until I was
in college and so I had to struggle in
college but I am no genius
owl and if I can do it I guarantee you
can do it don't miss that hard work
dedication and following a plan will
take you where you want to go I want you
to get so excited you can't sleep it's
time to get busy people because you got
stuff to do and guess what I've got more
ideas inspiration and action steps for
you check out my podcast retire inspire
Oh
[Music]